[Music]
all right boys lock and load
so what are we dealing with here gun
runners
gun dealers
it's two women who are counterfeiting
coupons
[Music]
this feels like a lot you don't think
we're coming in a little hot here balls
138 55 cents is it it's like a thousand
coupons
your trophy
yo yo yo it's time to save with jojo is
it hot in here or is it just me yes you
mom
we have a mountain of death is this the
best we're ever gonna do how come i'm so
broke
the system has set us up to fail
you know who gets rewarded people who
don't follow the rules
this time we start pending them a little
where did you get these
when you send these companies a
complaint they send you a coupon for
free stuff all of these free coupons
come from one factory it's like
robinhood we gotta steal these coupons
and sell them to families who really
need them that's money in the bank
[Music]
officer thousands of these coupons are
getting mailed out all over the country
we need boots on the ground
they'd be asap kilmer are us postal
inspector they said that they were
sending the fbi what do you do you carry
mail around or something that would be a
mailman they carry the mail i carry a
gun
we are investigating a counterfeit
coupon ring
costing companies tens of millions of
dollars
we need someone who's had experience
with this sort of thing
we've got to spread the [ __ ] out i'm
talking bank accounts credit cards the
stash house and aliases
could you say it all again and like much
slower and do you have like a pad just
to write it down no get out okay we
don't wing it that we got we got it
you got to let me in on this thing who's
the girl earl i think it's pretty clear
that earl doesn't know call a sketch
artist
call a sketch artist who do you think
[Music]
it's about the feeling again
they call it the coupon high
supposedly it's better than intimacy
with another person
that's why i've been told sorry have you
not used a coupon or have you not had
sex
what happened
the website is way too easy to trace
back to you is there anything else i
should know about think so no
well yo yo yo it's time to save with
jojo i mean how could they trace it
back to you yeah yeah my face is right
on it
[Music]
bye